من المحتمل أن يكون برج الساعة الأكثر شهرة
في العالم
رمزًا للديمقراطية البريطانية والحرية في لندن
التي كانت بحاجة ماسة إلى الادخار
منذ عام 2017 ، حيث كانت أصوات بيغ بن
صامتة بالكامل تقريبًا وحتى
وقت قريب كان برج إليزابيث
مختبئًا خلف سقالات تخضع لعملية تجديد
بقيمة 80 مليون جنيه إسترليني  إصلاح
الأسقف المتسربة والأعمال الحجرية المتهالكة من بين
أمور أخرى ، لقد استبدلنا الكثير من
الحجارة ، لقد استبدلنا كل
زجاج وجه الساعة حيث أزلنا
كل الحديد الزهر على مستوى السطح وقمنا
بإصلاحه ووضعه مرة أخرى
لم يُسمح للسائحين الدوليين أبدًا
بدخول البرج ، لكن
مؤرخ العقارات في البرلمان الدكتور مارك
كولينز يمكنه أن يأخذنا 399 خطوة إلى
الأعلى ويظهر لنا ما تغير
لدينا أحد الموانئ المصنوعة من الحديد الزهر الذي
يحتوي على 324 قطعة من زجاج أوبال المنفوخ بالفم
وجدنا ذلك  لم يكن في الواقع
طلاءًا أسود من الخارج ولكنه كان
لونًا أزرق بروسيًا زاهيًا للغاية والذي تم
إرجاعه الآن ستضيء مصابيح LED الجديدة الموفرة للطاقة
الساعات التي
سيتمكنون من تغيير لونها لدعم الأسباب
أو المهرجانات
[موسيقى]
تمت إزالة مئات التروس والسلاسل التي تدير عقارب الاتصال وتشغيل مطارق الجرس وتنظيفها ،
وهذا هو القطار الضارب وهو Big
Bear عندما
أعادت بيلا التعرف على آلية بيغ بن مرة أخرى
وستكون عملية التجديد الأجنبية كاملة
[موسيقى]
هي ساعة بيغ بن جرسنا التي تزن
أكثر من 13 طنًا ، وبعد ذلك ،
تمنح الأجراس الأربعة
أرباع وستمنستر المأخوذة من مسيح هاندل
[موسيقى  ]
بعد تثبيته ، ظهر صدع
في الجرس ولكن بدلاً من
استبداله ، تم
تقليل حجم المطرقة وتم
إخباره بملاحظة صوتية عميقة نظرًا
لأنه يمثل ملاحظة خطيرة بعد
شحن الربع
بعد الحروب المدمرة في  القرن العشرين
اكتسبت لعبة Big Ben معنى جديدًا ،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لعبت دورها
في احتفال في يوم الهدنة
لإحياء ذكرى الآلاف الذين لقوا حتفهم في
الحرب الأولى.  عندما نأتي إلى
الحرب العالمية الثانية ، يتم سماعها في جميع أنحاء العالم
يتم بثها بواسطة
BBC ويسمعها الناس ويعرفون أنه
لا يزال هناك بلد حر واحد في
أوروبا
الآن صعدنا 399 درجة إلى
أعلى نقطة في البرج و  نحن
ننظر إلى الأرض والنور
عندما يكون مجلس اللوردات أو
مجلس العموم جالسًا بعد
حلول الظلام ، يتم تشغيل الأرض والضوء
في أعلى البرج خلف
التذهيب الذي تم ترميمه
واستبداله بمناظر 360 درجة فريدة
عبر المدينة نزولاً إلى ساحة البرلمان و
Westminster Abbey وفوق نهر التايمز في
جنوب لندن
، أصبح برج الساعة
سمة من سمات لندن ، حيث يحتوي على إعلانات احتفالية
أو أنه يحتوي على نوع من الألعاب مثل السحر
، وأعتقد الآن أنه أه  عاد
إلى هذا النوع من الرعونة التي كان عليها
مع استبدال التذهيب بالكامل ونظام
الألوان الجديد أعتقد أنه يبدو
مميزًا جدًا حقًا